[Music]
you
I really love the imaginary foundation
the imaginary foundation is a think tank
clandestine mysterious think tank it's
Switzerland that has created a peril as
a conduit to spread the power of human
imagination now what's most amazing
about the imaginary foundation is the
mesozoic gasm excitement trophic
dimension of its imagery the places that
the images convey the places that they
induce inside of the viewer the cosmic
link that reverberates and your very
being when you consume the imagery just
to me is astonishing wherever that place
is that the artists behind that is privy
to thank you for sharing a twinkle of
that reverence with the rest of us
here's to the director the imaginary
foundation
[Music]
Oh